ils sortent de leur droit de réserve
pour lancer un cri d'alerté les chefs
d'établissement de collèges et lycées
sont à bout de souffle une enquête
nationale fait apparaître une
dégradation des conditions de travail
des personnels d'encadrement et des
risques pour leur santé très important
christophe taris bamba guèye bâ se passe
bien
sans calme aller à la rencontre de ses
élèves arpenter les couloirs de son
établissement des missions que patrick
genthod ne fait presque plus 25 ans qui
les proviseurs mais désormais le plus
clair de son temps il le passe ici dans
son bureau à répondre à ces trois boîtes
mail croulant sous l'administratif
mon quotidien a réellement changé est ce
que je regrette beaucoup c'est que
l'élève ne soit plus au centre ce que
j'ai pu le temps de m'occuper en fait
d'eux des projets pour les élèves et
qu'on est complètement dans
l'administratif dans la jonque tiff dans
les mails qui nous arrive à vitesse
grand v nous font faire des réponses
aussi rapide un sentiment partagé par
bon nombre de ses collègues à bout de
souffle en fatigue est pour l'instant un
type aussi en arrivant plus en arrivant
d'une autre académie on redécouvre
d'autres nouveau mode de fonctionnement
un rapport pointe du doigt une
profession en crise aux conditions de
travail dégradées que le coville n'a pas
arrangé en proie à des troubles du
sommeil et même pour 13 % d'entre eux a
des envies suicidaires
dans l'académie tige
dans une autre académie mais nous avons
effectivement chez les collègues des
collègues qui ne recourent plus la plus
importante aux arrêts maladie et aussi
des collègues qui déclarent renoncer à
des soins faute de temps je volonté
d'achever deux minutes malgré ce qu'en
témoigne est victime d'un burn out alors
qu'il gérait la cité scolaire de digoin
en saône et loire une surcharge de
travail un sentiment d'abandon et une
fin de carrière difficile
j'étais arrêté en gros sur cinq ans
j'étais arrêté quasiment deux ans et
j'en pouvais vraiment plu et je n'ai pas
terminé l'année scolaire dernière j'ai
arrêté au 1er mars alors qu'en général
on termine l'année scolaire j'ai dit non
je ne mets pas ma santé en jeu je
m'arrête si le rectorat est à l' écoute
ses appels à l'aide doivent surtout
interpeller le ministère alors que
l'évocation se font aussi de plus en
plus rares